منذ اندلاع حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا ساد
الاعتقاد ان هناك تفوقا استخباراتيا
امريكيا ساعد كثيرا الجيش الاوكراني الان
يعلن البونتاجون انه يحقق في تسريب وثائق
سريه تتعلق بالاعداد لهجوم اوكرانيا
المضاد المتوقع هذا الربيع الوثائق نشرت
في منصات التواصل الاجتماعي ومنها تويتر
وكذا انستغرام الذي يستخدمه نصف مليار شخص
ويكتسب شعبيه كبيره بروسيا وسائل الاعلام
الروسيه نشرت الوثائق على نطاق واسع فيما
يشبه الاحتفاء بنصر استخباراتي لا يمكن
الاعلان عنه رسميا تقدم هذه الوثائق
معلومات حساسه عن الجدول الزمني لتسليم
الاسلحه الغربيه لاوكرانيا وقائمه بوحدات
الجيش الاوكراني ومعداته وتدريباته رغم
انها لا تشير الى تاريخ بدء هجوم الربيع
او مكانه الوثائق بها معلومات في غايه
الاهميه عن 12 لواء في الجيش الاوكراني
يجري تدريب تسعه منها في الولايات المتحده
ودول اخرى في النيتو ويتوقع ان تكون سته
منها جاهزه في نهايه مارس ويقدر الخبراء
عدد العسكريين في كل دول بما بين اربعه
الاف وخمسه الاف تشير الوثائق الى ان
الانويه تسعه ستحتاج 250 دبابه وثلاثمائه
وخمسين الي عسكريه اخرى كما تقدم معلومه
مهمه اخرى عن سرعه استجابه القوات
الاوكرانيه للتعامل مع قذائف هاي مارس وهي
معلومه لم يقدمها من قبل لكن مصادر رسميه
امريكيه حذرت من ان بعض الوثائق المنشوره
مزوره بهدف تحقيق الدعايه الروسيه ومنها
وثيقه تقلل عدد ضحايا روسيا وتضخم عدد
ضحايا اوكرانيا في الحرب ورغم ان بعض
الوثائق مزوره فان البانتاكن يعترف بان
اخرى سديمه وتتضمن معلومات في غايه
الاهميه
وقد توقع خبراء لصحيفه ان تستفيد روسيا من
هذه الوثائق المسربه وان كان من الصعب
تحديد مدى هذه الاستفاده كما يتوقعون ان
تؤثر على تبادل المعلومات بين الولايات
المتحده واوكرانيا التي ترددت في السابق
في مد واشنطن في معلومات ميدانيه خوفا من
هذا النوع من التسريبات